thank you for joining us the united
nations secretary general antonia
gutierrez has hold a face-to-face
meeting in moscow with russia's
president it's the first time the u.n
chief has visited russia since the war
in ukraine began guterres has offered
for the united nations to help directly
with the safe evacuation of the as
hostile plant in the besieged ukrainian
city of mariopol that's where at least a
thousand civilians remain trapped
president president putin has called
what's unfolding in mario paul a
difficult and tragic situation and said
he hopes that talks with ukraine would
yield positive results
there are no military actions being
conducted in the avoc style steel
factory we heard from the ukrainian
government that there are civilians
inside the compound in that case
ukrainian military personnel are obliged
to let them go the simple thing is with
regards to evacuating those people mr
secretary general you have been deceived
and misled over a hundred thousand
people have left mario paul they can go
anywhere they want some people want to
go to russia some to ukraine
we need to work together with the armed
forces of russia and the armed forces of
ukraine so that we can resolve the
problem
this would be an initial operation to
evacuate civilians from the factory
russia has constantly accused that this
evacuation was never carried out russia
also declared that safe passage has
never been used to evacuate those
civilians
now in a moment we will be speaking to
our diplomatic editor james space at the
united nations about the importance of
this trip for the u.n secretary general
but first to dr jabari in moscow dosa
what more has come out of that meeting
between the russian leader and the u.n
chief
well
the u.n secretary general
was here on a
mission for peace and we have just
received a readout from the united
nations press office who issued a
statement following a two-hour meeting
between vladimir putin and antonio
guterres and according to the un
statement the
russian president vladimir putin has
agreed in principle to
an agreement that would see the united
nations and the international committee
for the red cross uh facilitate the exit
of those civilians that are held uh hold
up in the azov style steel plant and
this evacuation would of course be with
the coordination of the russian defense
ministry as well as ukrainian officials
according to this statement from the
united nations
the russian president and the secretary
general have agreed to conduct a
follow-up discussion with
the un office for the coordination of
humanitarian affairs as well as the
russian defense ministry so
seemingly the impossible task of
achieving any kind of a
resolution to any of the ongoing crises
that are happening in ukraine has been
achieved for now in theory by antonio
guterres now
we understand that this meeting that
lasted two hours between guterres and
putin
was seemingly cordial and they had a lot
to discuss and prior to that meeting
the two men spoke briefly
the russian president saying that he
valued the core principles of
which the united nations was founded on
and russia as one of the founding
members will continue to support this
organization and the important work that
it does he acknowledged that the u.n is
tasked with resolving uh crises that
occur urgently around the world and this
situation in ukraine is certainly one of
them for his part the um secretary
general did not mince any words he held
his ground firmly when addressing
vladimir putin and
reaffirming his belief that this
so-called special military operation by
the russian forces is very much an
invasion uh as far as the united nations
is concerned based on their charter and
it is the um russian forces that have
invaded sovereign territory as a result
of what they believed to be a just cause
but regardless he said that they view it
as an invasion now the two men also
discussed of course the uh ongoing
negotiations that are taking place
between the ukrainian and russian side
and the russian president said that
although he believes they are at a a
stencil or a dead end at the moment
there's still hope that they will
achieve something uh in the end and they
in that hope are continuing the daily
discussions between the two sides dorset
thank you very much for that dorsa
jabari live forest day in moscow let's
now bring in our diplomatic editor james
space at the united nations james talk
to us about the importance of this visit
for the united nations secretary general
he's not just going to moscow but also
to keith later
he is personally investing himself in
diplomacy after two months of war he's
decided this is the right time he
believes that he can make a difference
but he knows that this was always going
to be a very difficult meeting with
president putin he got the long table
treatment from the russian president and
there was a pretty frank exchange of
views in the bit that was on camera
you certainly got the russian president
saying some of those things he said in
the past
repeating some of the lines that he said
in the past and the secretary general
holding his ground too
saying at one point i strongly believe
in international law we believe there
was an invasion of ukraine now he knows
the audience is not just in moscow he
wants to persuade the russians of his um
his aims which are humanitarian but also
he's got to go to keeve where they're
also a little bit uh unhappy that he
went to moscow first president zielenski
has said that was the wrong order um and
uh that they're a little bit miffed that
he's traveled to moscow first uh and i
think that's why one of the reasons why
the secretary general has been quite
tough in his meetings with president
putin what he's focusing on very
narrowly is humanitarian affairs because
that's where he thinks he can do
something they're going to have a new
humanitarian contact group if he gets
his way with ukraine russia and the
united nations to try and solve some of
the urgent humanitarian
problems around the country but i think
the urgent thing is mariopol and there
you've got the un and the international
committee of the red cross planning a
new effort at evacuation and when i
asked a u.n spokesperson a short time
ago about that about whether this uh new
effort could take place while the
secretary general is on ukrainian soil
and he's traveling to ukraine in the
next 24 hours i was told they're working
as hard as they can to make this happen
as fast as possible the secretary
general's trip has been arranged pretty
last minute there's still lots of
security concerns about the trip so very
fluid situation and very fluid in terms
of what he's achieving uh certainly he's
got the russians to say
they'll accept this new initiative on
mariopol but there's now work to be done
between u.n officials humanitarian
officials and the russian defense
ministry and then of course they've got
to add in the ukrainian side to this
james thank you very much james space is
our diplomatic editor live there at the
united nations